BACK TODLEY BEAL.
THAT WAS
THE JAZZ IN TRANSITION. .
BE B.
LONG. UP REBANDING UTAH
BY SEVEN.
25 POINTS PAINT. CLOCK.
WILL TAKE A DEEP
INSIDEFOR EIGHT POINTS.
THE
BASKETS.
>> Craig: HERE IS
HE IS NOT A GREAT PLAYMAKER AS
MUCH AS HE IS A RE IT BACK.
KICK IT PLAY.
>> HE IS.
THE BULLS.
>> IT WAS ACTUALLY A GREAT
CLEVELAND WITH MULTIPLE
TURNOVERS, AND THERE IS ONE
RIGHT TH
BACK AND FORTH IN THE EARLY
GOING. TEAMING MITCHELL.
CONTACT, BUT
HE GETS RUN UP FOR A FOUL ON THE
.
JAZZ NEED TO FIND OUT.
>> Craig: OH.
THE BUCKET BY
MAKE IT FIVE.
SURVEYING , DONOVAN, DRIVING. T.
WE'RE SO NEEDY.
WE'RE REBOUNDING, WE'RE
>> ON THE PLAY.
MITCHELL BACK IN THE BILLILI
DRIVE. SECOND
CHANCE.X-POINT UTAH LEAD.
HOWHREE
ASSISTS.: : RIRIGHGHT T TITIMEM.
MITCHELL.
PUMPED UP THEGO.
9 CHANGES AND 4 TIES IN THE
FIFION THE GLASS AND MADE IT
LOOK EASY. IN THE SECOND
ON THAT IT CAN BE A LITTLE BIT .
OUOUT T OFOF T THEHE UTAH TRYIN
BACK.
HAD THAT ACHILLES INJURY.
WHAT
FEEL IT.
THEY GOT THE MOMENT